[Música]
há cerca de 20 anos
perdi a visão não gosto de falar isso
publicamente porque é uma forma de
agradecer o espetáculo porque seria uma
forma de fugir a uma identidade
deficitária
eu gosto de definir como qualquer um nós
enquanto pessoa por aquilo que faço o
que faço todos os dias pela minha
profissão e minha família e não por ter
uma deficiência center fazê lo porque o
tema é confiança
eu disse que foi há cerca de 20 anos
porque não foi um dia para o outro foi
qualquer coisa que foi acontecendo com o
retrocesso a risadas com pressões com
dez operações puma e até que visam se
perdeu completamente e é evidente que
num processo deste longo
houve muitos momentos de incerteza e de
insegurança do perdão total confiança
nos outros os médicos principalmente
embora a culpa não fosse deus é uma
doença que ultrapassei muita medicina
ainda mais sobretudo em mim como é que
vai ser o mundo o meu mundo daqui pra
frente
curiosa coincidência fosse aqui já muito
pouco tempo
camilo castelo branco presidência porque
nasci na mesma cidade camilo no porto
mas sim no mesmo dia de camilla 1 desde
o mês de março
cheguei com a mesma doença caiu a um
glaucoma
só ainda não vem tendo na cabeça como
camilo
espero um ano e é o que é que o que terá
feito a diferença
talvez eu tenha tido condições de
recuperação da confiança que eu não ter
também passaram 130 anos porém tanto o
mundo mudou o que é confiança
é convicção de que os outros vão
comportar do modo como estamos à espera
estamos à espera que se comporta de
acordo com normas socialmente
consensualizadas aceites como válidas e
como tais
portanto podemos dizer que a confiança é
vazio da vida social
o cotidiano mais banal das jóias na
confiança
nós só saímos de manhã automóvel ainda
nos convencionais neste que ainda somos
nós que conduzimos porque temos a
certeza que toda a outra gente vai
conduzir por um lado direito da estrada
se não fosse ninguém sair de casa dalton
o contrário da confiança e esta ideia é
um social inglês anthony rylands disco
contrário da confiança não é
desconfiança é o mesmo
é uma sedado que o mundo não funciona
uma ansiedade você maria existencial
a confiança é tanto mais importante
quanto mais a nona emissão os contextos
em que estamos e quanto mais de
incerteza e situação que vivemos diz
logo após o próprio contexto
sociocultural e como é que nas de
confiança mas quando nós temos nós nos
primeiros laços estão os seus com as
figuras cuidadoras naturalmente um
conjunto de especialistas sobre mental
a seguir à segunda guerra mundial foi
fazendo uma série de trabalhos com
crianças vítimas de abandono das figuras
cuidadoras principalmente da mãe que por
norma a regra é aquela que mais cuidados
têm conhecido e mais próximo eu amo
alguns destes
alguns mineiros ficaram pastoreia da
saúde mental e da psicologia e
psicopedagogia na flórida é filha da
noiva john obi remexe pizza
tire da implosão muito estranho um vídeo
falar diz muito simplesmente eu diria
que é fumada para explicar como é que
estes primeiros laços entre bb e os
cuidadores criam todo o reservatório é
que você marcou mas a vitória dá
confiança
o resto da vida e tv com confortos estes
cuidados têm a ver com o modo como é
criança pode usufruir de um clima
tranqüilo à sua volta de um clima em que
sentiu tocada e amava ninguém tocava
porque o primeiro mundial que tem como
uma criatura que ainda não fala como
aconteceu todos nós que aqui estamos
durante os dois primeiros anos de vida
o primeiro contacto contactável um
contato corpo a corpo
já me chamaram bipolaridade tatchell
eu quando toco solto caso o bebê é
tocava e aprenda a tocar mesmo quando
ainda não faz com as mãos e falou do
primeiro com o boca quando mama por
exemplo é importante e vai aprendendo
fronteira através do toque entre eu ea
mãe deles love e entre eu eo mundo
portanto podemos dizer que pérola é o
primeiro órgão que estabelece os limites
entre o eu e os outros e portanto é o
primeiro órgão que estabelece a
confiança e todo este todo este
autonômico entre coisas hora cuidadora
eo bebê é préval muito embora os outros
para falar com a criança dela não
responderam chegam com sons e com mix e
e então fizemos um primeiro contato
efetivo
isto é ternura e tadeu ea ternura o
afeto são as primeiras formas de
construção do psiquismo de outra maneira
o psiquismo nasce no corpo estão a
expansão através de eu temos no eu
corporal
o primeiro modelo do e psíquico estou a
citar uma psicanalista brasileira a
telefones fontes
aliás é ela que fala do tributável eu
trouxe paguei pouco porque parece uma
opção muito forte que é extremamente
lúcida ativa do que estou a procurar
explicar
vivemos hoje uma crise de confiança é
como mover se diz eu vou assinar esta
questão com duas etiquetas que
habitualmente opomos à sociedade ou a
sociedade em que vivemos atualmente
seriam sociedade do risco por um lado e
seriam sociedades a transferência pronto
sociedade do risco é fria hoje uma
infinidade de riscos à nossa volta
será que sim nós temos os mais inseguros
mas esportes do que tivemos no passado
objectivamente não acontece a gente fez
caminho e continuar a ser identificada
que ela usava o nome de sua visão de
costumes anunciada por baterias e
organismos que ao longo da história
sobretudo damos unidade
nós fomos capazes de fazer retrair
centro
o risco em veias morte a morte física a
morte física é hoje menos provável é
mais difícil morrer
nós conseguimos controlar muito mais os
fatores de risco da doença e da morte
sejam riscos biológicos sejam riscos
sociais portanto não deveríamos estar
aqui militar na idéia de uma sociedade
risco porque isso acontece então por que
o ipê representamos e perda representa o
amor fruto das tecnologias de
comunicação desde logo da provisão que
começa a estar um pouco de morrer faz
outras formas fazer circular imagem
seja como for e para representarmos o
risco
todos nos lembramos do 11 de setembro e
10 mil vezes que vimos nos dias
seguintes nos meses seguintes em 23
enquanto e possui ainda muito pouco
tempo sobre o último dos atentados
magnetizados na escala global foi a nova
zelândia
o procurador votar filmou em directo o
que estava a fazer e muita gente viu em
directo um ataque terrorista
portanto todo este conjunto de
circulação de rumores cruzando de
imagens escuridão antes faz com que nós
criamos uma apresentação do mundo
inseguro do mundo perigoso cidade
resposta eu penso que a metáfora que
explica hoje a cidade ao nível das
nossas representações nossas imagens de
ser a resposta ainda uma outra
circunstância acrescentar esta é que
vivemos ensinar sua história o estado
gasta se própria tarefa de nos proteger
o euro faz te e fomos fomos mimados
postados digamos assim que nos garantiu
que nos produzido ea vida e portanto
lidamos muito mal coisa e de insegurança
e risco
paradoxalmente quanto mais seguros
estamos mais mesmo temos torres kuhn e
agora é questão da cidade a experiência
porque trago pra que nas cidades de
pequena escala interação entre nós era
mais densa em que o conhecimento faça
fácil estava muito mais expandido nas
comunidades
o vínculo central era da confiança a
confiança significa que eu posso não
conhecer o outro quase não conhecer mas
posso confiar nem eu chamo alguém a
minha casa para preparar um
eletrodoméstico
eu posso não conhecer a pessoa mas
acredito que ela vai lá entrar vai fazer
o que tem que fazer
não vai faltar nem falar no dia seguinte
quando eu chegar em casa
da mesma forma que a pessoa vai confiar
que faz o serviço e eu só lhe paga no
fim mas que vou pagar
este é o vínculo da confiança é o
vínculo que apesar de tudo ainda
prevalece na vida social recorrentes
acontece que é fruto do grande
crescimento dos aglomerados de
metropolização das nossas vidas nós cada
vez mais nos 8 mil
vamos social - cada vez mais estamos
entregues a nós próprios
muitos dizem que vivemos na sociedade do
hiper individualismo
nestas condições mais do que comunicavam
o que nós temos são agregados de
indivíduos agregados negros que até
podem perseguir interesses comuns porque
tem três todos os réus no mesmo objetivo
alguém já falou nos branco mini itx as
comunidades de marca por exemplo não
chega a ser uma comunidade no sentido
teremos o termo qualquer coisa tem que
ficar com o caminho ao nível do que é
confiança e quando não podemos confiar o
mecanismo que substitui é transparência
se eu não posso conhecer outro outra vez
um vínculo próximo quer que haja um
mecanismo que garanta a transparência
daquela pessoa e é por isso que nós hoje
estamos a exigir aos detentores de
cargos públicos
publiquem suas declarações de
rendimentos é por isso que o parlamento
português criou uma comissão por a
transparência é por isso que vivemos uma
espécie um pornô pico nos vigia por
todos os lados vigilâncias eletrônicas
estamos sujeitos a transparência agora
não nos iludamos
a transparência não é a restauração da
confiança
a transparência é solucionar do control
são mecanismos postos em marcha para
garantirmos que continuaremos a
funcionária na qual a presença do outro
sem estes nos trair permanentemente e
agora vou juntar alguns destes segmentos
que tenho de transmitir até agora quer
dizer o seguinte parece que confiança
estrutura pelo menos em dois níveis no
nível sensorial e no nível internacional
e como é que este processo nas pessoas
que perderam a visão no nível sensorial
temos que voltar a confiar no corpo a
primeira coisa que acontece quando não
se vê é não saber em que direção caminha
dar um passo a seguir ao outro é
caminhar num vazio encaminhar uma
espécie um do leite branquinho
o o cinzento das pessoas
os novos visuais imaginam que o sexo com
seus péssimos escuridão um impenetrável
e talula não não é bem isso há uns que
vem e brancos cinzentos vive no meu caso
tenho uma série de brilhos vão
habituando à volta deles não
correspondem a nenhum estímulo externo
seja como for a avançar contra estas
cortinas é qualquer coisa que implica
restaurar a confiança no corpo
isto faça através por exemplo da
atividade física e voltar a ganhar
confiança numa actividade desportiva por
exemplo na reabilitação do cego é
importante pólo a mexer o corpo por lá
avançar sem mesmo a sensualidade tátil e
tal foi tão importante na nossa primeira
infância deve ser recuperada em toda a
sua plenitude
o corpo é muito importante do nosso
corpo tem potencialidade extraordinários
enquanto o dispositivo do conhecimento
do mundo e vivemos mochi lava que
utiliza mais pra imagem
os integrantes e companhia do que
propriamente como dispositivos
conhecimentos verdadeiro tanto em
primeiro lugar esta questão da
instauração da restauração sensorial um
outro nível da restauração prende-se com
o plano interativo
nós somos animal animais do pequeno
grupo mesmo quando chegamos em grandes
cidades
nós já criamos um pequeno grupo da
família com a escola nos amigos nos
grupos de pertença no trabalho e e e
qualidade destes contextos nos quais
promovem interação é fundamental a
qualidade do infantário do jardim de
infância e creche e qualidade das
escolas básicas e secundárias das
universidades e qualidade dos contextos
trabalho é qualquer coisa que vale a
pena apostar mais uma qualidade em que
haja toda uma educação para a inclusão
das pessoas com diferenças e diferenças
temos todos
caetano veloso diz uma das suas letras
que de perto ninguém é normal
portanto temos de vencer temos que que
pretende aprender ou continuar todos e
querer aprender esta tolerância para com
a diferença e suas com textos forem
interativos forem deus
restaram total confiança própria acha a
as comunidades a pequena escala nas
quais ela é ouvindo primordial
portanto eu diria que tivermos condições
para trabalhar feito na restauração de
pessoas que conseguiremos isso aponta as
deficiências também na instalação do
plano cultural da confiança vou chamar
da confiança
siga corporal trabalhando a consciência
corporal e como desculpa ao trabalho a
partir do tatu todos nós também os
normal visuais prevendo o tabu do toque
perdendo o tabu da distância do olhar
desconfiavam anos nós conseguimos fazer
esta educação para a psicóloga
corporalidade e se conseguirmos
trabalhar para a melhor qualidade dos
nossos contextos estaremos em condições
vai comprar a recuperar a confiança
dizer o seguinte a confiança não é uma
característica não é um estado
responsável querido uma vez por todas e
depois vemos já está já sou confiante
não não é isso a confiança é volúvel é o
lábio ela anda pra cima e pra baixo
dependendo muito dos acontecimentos
fulcrais da nossa vida
dependendo do modo como os que nos
rodeiam dão suporte às nossas crises
pessoais e e e portanto vale a pena
tentarmos procurar melhor do que saber
quais são os grandes construtores de
confiança eu sou nem fundamentalmente os
psicológicos mas também os interativos e
e socioculturais sabemos quais são
os construtores da confiança do modo
podemos agir mais intencionalmente nela
de cada vez que podemos dizer
[Aplausos]